[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm toasted I can live my toast to the
lovers and so see you doin oh my god I
am I inhales for the goood 11:00 at
night choke dancin I have a stumbled
over the groom I know I inhaled
underrated okay tripped over myself I'm
actually okay actually now it hurts a
little bit ready okay
good morning Millennials happy Tuesday
welcome back to the morning trust I am
back from Milwaukee very happy to be
here couldn't have loved the Milwaukee
toasters any more like what a crowd what
it just is like a good vibe people you
know like they just like love where
they're from and like I really enjoyed
them that's exciting you guys have a
good time and it was very short like the
second we got to the hotel we had to
leave like it was in and out which I
love because I'd love to just be in my
own bed but me and Margo had quite an
experience on our flight home oh we did
right we're with the class night oh yeah
so me and Margaret well we're at the
Pabst Theater in Milwaukee which is a
great venue and it has three major rooms
that you can perform and obviously the
biggest one I was not in I was in like
one of the smaller ones and one of the
guys at the venue told me that Jim
Gaffigan is playing there that night and
I was like oh can I get a ticket but our
shows were at the same time so like me
Margo really had wanted to go but we
were on at the same time so there's no
way I could have one and then we murder
in the Milwaukee Airport yesterday
morning and we're sitting at the gate
and Jim Gaffigan comes over and I just
want to say we were sitting there and I
didn't look up I heard he has the most
distinctive voice he has someone at the
desk something so I heard his voice and
I was like no way Margaret this Jim
Hawkins here like I just need to look up
to confirm it but I knew like we loved
him
and it was just like so crazy and he sat
down at the gate he was eating a
sandwich he was very on bran like the
whole thing you know and I wasn't gonna
bother him when he was eating and I
really want to bother him at all but
like Margo was like really like pushing
me to do it she had to you see Haley
comment yeah no I know but like I just
don't get the type of guy who does not
like to be bothered you know yeah I know
I understand why you were trepidatious
yeah you had to so everyone stood up to
board and I just
tap-tap and I was like I just want to
say I'm a huge fan like I love your
special and he was like thanks and like
I was really awkward and I just like
wanted to die you know and it was not
like the magical meeting like he didn't
ask me to go on tour with him like
that's what I thought was gonna happen
you know and I was like I was like damn
I wish I didn't do that it was I was so
awkward I was like hey Brenda celebrity
like it has the potential to ruin that
celebrity for you just because you
cringe at the thought of yourself like
that celebrity could have been fine but
like when you think about the way that
you behaved it's like you you can't
think about this person it would like
literally Jackie once I was like there I
had like a tear in my eye I was like I
was so awkward it was just like the body
language was not there and like I was
really I'm like that's my meeting with
Jim Gaffigan like I'm so upset you know
that happened with us with Madeline
patch oh my god it wasn't just that she
goes app it she was into you guys she
yeah it was she probably like wasn't her
fault it's like just but the way that we
approached it right
you know it's every to mutual you know
in each hooker yeah so me and Mauro then
boarded like three people behind him he
was sitting in row two
I was sitting in row three so I got up
to row two and I put my bag up to row
two and thankfully me and Margo we're
both wearing the new merch the teal TMT
sweaters which are flying off the
shelves like stocking our new yet it's
harder to get then Virgil for Louboutin
than herpes yeah actually yeah um so
putting my bags up and he's like staring
at me oh my god when I was gonna say
anything and then he's like what is that
like your sweatshirt and I was like oh
it's my podcast he's like what's it
called and I said the morning toast and
then he goes do you have another podcast
I'm like no he's a girl I'm like oh girl
with no job yeah I'm the one who's
always commenting on your instagrams and
he was like yeah you were at the peps
theater last night I'm like yes I was I
guess we were like on the bill together
like maybe he saw a picture of me like
when he was walking down the hallway you
know yeah and I was like yes and I like
this my sister Mario and then we had
like a lovely you know real it was like
peers chatting you know as as peers do
and it was just like such a better way
to have met Jim getting like when I have
to tell people the story I'm going to
lead out the beginning partner you know
but you'll tell your closest just
toasters right know and like if anyone
asks like Jim Gaffigan like recognizing
he recognized recognize me he did yeah
it was very humbling because he was like
staring at us as we were walking and I
was like I
feel like he's about to say something or
eat or he's just like why are these
losers matching right he's like what's
TMT just thinking right yeah but like he
was looking with the clothes I was like
hmm but it's just so crazy cuz like he's
just like a regular guy like but he's
like literally one of the biggest
touring acts in the world and like I was
watching him the whole fight I'm like
what does one of the most successful
comedians in the world do on a play what
does he do so he had this big stack of
papers it looked like he was a professor
grading papers me thinks he's probably
writing jokes but he had like you know
those paper clips that are like black
and little he like had that who's a real
teacher vibe like a professor aesthetic
needs a script oh yes I mean he was
Johnny some things down and then he fell
asleep and then when we landed I saw him
tweet something and then I like went to
his Twitter on my phone to like see what
it was and it's like a trailer for some
movie he's in I was just so shocked by
how normal he was like Kevin Hart
doesn't travel like that yeah and
they're equally as successful in terms
of touring just like he is huge and he
had like no security just yeah it was
crazy a plain old play Jane yeah
on the plane a plane play then like I
was sitting right behind him and I was
like thinking about all the funny things
he's like said in his specials he was
like do you know what who's funny look
and then I was like laughing behind him
like giggling at his jokes I think I
know the moral of the story here
okay it's that if you want to have like
a positive conversation with a celebrity
and get ready recognized you need to be
wearing mourning toes merch no I just
want to say like nothing bad has ever
come from wearing mourning shows man
only good things oh my god oh it says -
had this crazy man sat next to me on the
plane and he first sat down he's like
where's her friend I was like what he's
like yeah don't match the suitcases in
the matching sweater we also had our
pink away suitcases we looked like
incredible losers yeah it was a good
thing Feliz - yeah oh my god I was
wearing my pink pillows so we were
everyone apparently noticed it was a
plane of 20 people alike yeah we were
shocking looking from Wisconsin right
like they never saw I don't see that
think they see that much pink on also
another interesting factoid that I think
you will find particularly interesting
is Jim Gaffigan had an away suitcase
what color black
interés on yeah quite I was really just
like obsessed with like watching him it
was really a great experience I'm so
happy for I've never been on a plane
with a real slab ever really the one
time Devon Windsor was on my flight
one time I was with Stanley Tucci Jackie
this guy was sitting in coach on the
flight back from LA it was like
literally rotating it was exits shut up
Josh you know he's texting all of us you
guys I'm sitting next assembly chuchi
and we we're all sitting on different
parts of the plane and then when we're
leaving Jackie's pointing I think that's
him and we're like that is not it was
not him he was just bald and glasses
using kognito
but that actually reminds me of a story
that I didn't get to share on the toast
about city Nexus celebrities on planes
on my way back from LA I was flying LAX
to JFK and it's always a star-studded
affair that Delta line LAX JFK on my way
there I saw Margaret Cho it was it's
always just like a good time and on my
way back I'm sitting and the person next
me doesn't show up which means only one
thing when you're flying LAX JFK a
celebrity's coming they board very last
and they get escorted and it was just
like really excited and then all of a
sudden I look up in the flight
attendants bringing my seatmate and it's
Henry wiggler yeah the funds or whatever
it is and I was like oh my god I was so
excited and he was like a round Russian
of time and he was like oh hi and I'm
like hi and I'm like join me and then he
goes will you switch seats with my wife
and I was like fine and so I did and
then the flight attendant fall to me and
so what's Henry Winkler he grabbed my
cheek and he said Shanah Tovah and I
said thank you had a mean glare and he's
just such a great affair and then he was
talking to me the whole time like he was
such a nice guy like truly he felt like
the grandpa of the plane you know he was
everyone's grandfather yeah
I can't deal with a cheek crab but I'm
happy for you regarding it was very
sweet he had soft hands I didn't mind it
no that's I love Henry it's so late I
wasn't wearing makeup if I was wearing
makeup I would have been I don't even
know what the right word it's like for
how it was sounded I would have been
like yeah no I had fresh face I didn't
care okay
fresh watch fresh five speaking of five
she has four teman feels perfect just
another night being my son sleeping in
my crotch like I you I can't ask for
anything else that's what I'm saying you
know it's like that's such a special
bond that we have and I feel lucky and
grateful to be his mother every day of
my life Wow
I love
here it yeah and I have I have fake
botch in my home oh right oh my god so
at the meet and greet in Wisconsin first
of all I got some of the best guys ever
you are going to love this story this
girl comes up so the way that it works
in Mean Green is that they collect all
the gifts and they put it on a table so
this girl like your bat mitzvah yeah
this girl came and she was like I'm
these two girls they were like super
cute I'm like we're so sorry like we
went to dinner and we like took home our
leftovers and I guess that people here
thought that it was a gift for you so
our leftovers just like a half-eaten
pizza and like some spaghetti in a bag
for you and I was like honestly it's
best gift I ever got that's hilarious
and then to camp toasters member lauryn
Hakeem eg4 and Lisa they came to the
show and they brought me there's this
company where you can upload pictures
and dimensions and get a stuffed animal
that's an exact replica of your dog so I
opened the box and at first I screamed I
thought it was a real dog and then I
just opened it and I was just like oh my
god it was so amazing and then it was
like in our hotel room he was in the
greenroom and it was freaking me out
like it looks so much like Theo and just
like the same coloring and the scene he
mentions like it was so freaky but it
was truly one of the greatest gifts I
ever got we need to get it to taste see
how he reacts yeah he's hitting me
freaked out he's gonna be freaked out
you should keep it you should keep it no
then you should bring it on tour with us
everywhere we go oh that's cute like a
lot of space yeah we only carry on
except this week oh my god I forgot we
have such a busy week tomorrow's Yom
Kippur I'm looking for us well we will
be praying for you I'll be repenting
atoning apologizing stop in my chest
like such a hard day I'm really not
looking forward to like facing my sins
my sin it's like I'm you know they say
in like the last 10 days like the 10
days leading up to you are like you're
supposed to be better you know yeah like
do some repentance and I feel like I
have it I feel like I've been really
trying to draw back on my [ __ ] talking
and it's so hard like it's literally my
job that's true there was like one
instance where I was like committing
Lashon Hara and I was like blush in her
is gossip in Hebrew I was I was thinking
I was like these are the 10 days like
I'm just gonna stop ya no no like that's
always the one it's like every year you
think I'd be like throwing a ball I said
having a spinster is this it oh that is
really interesting
you think that's sharing
screaming someone's picture and sending
to someone is a sin that is life I don't
think having a fenced and strong young
people is the crime I think the crime is
then sending and like making fun or
gossiping yeah okay but okay say I don't
write anything I just screenshot
something and send it to someone no you
know without and I don't say anything
mean about it I'm just like sharing and
for me so there's an underlying tone
you're not sharing it because you think
it's cool like I think it's it's so lush
and horror II yeah but what about when
someone's like doing they're posting
something so cringe-worthy
no I know it's like you reacting to it
and feeling like it's cringe isn't the
sin the sin is then sharing it and
making fun of the person like with your
friends or sisters
well luckily like I don't partake very
much in Finn sting
I'm just really feel like if there's
someone that I hate enough to follow
like they deserve my follow because
that's how I feel about people with me
like if you are just like looking at my
page to lurk like the least you could do
is follow me yeah and by the way like I
don't look at my views I don't know I
won't you know yeah no no I know you
know um but anyways we are having to LA
this Saturday which is very exciting
because we are kicking off toast la week
lining up some amazing guests we are
kicking off the week with my show at the
Ace Theatre Sunday tickets available a
car with no job com I'm very excited and
then Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
we're not Monday Oh Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday
sorry we are banging out some premium
toast episodes we're gonna have guests
it's not gonna be live but it's gonna be
podcast and video uploaded to our
podcast channel and to our YouTube
channel so don't worry you could watch
or listen and then me and Margaret
headed to San Diego in San Francisco on
Friday I got one show in San Diego
tickets available no job calm and two
shows in San Francisco I believe they
might be sold out but feel free to check
it out you know you can get updates did
I mention it's at girl with my job calm
nice well I'm feeling very promo tea
today make that coin anything else um
just like felt my Instagram follow
through on Instagram pub with no job
even though his social media manager has
like taking a hiatus you know we'll see
how he's interesting because he's kind
of like he doesn't want to share too
much with the public like he wants to
keep think some things private and but
he knows that people do need that dose
of precious gem every once in a while
but he's just really keeping to himself
also he doesn't leave his house
so there's not so much he can do no but
like his mother does send the social
media manager excuse me what she thinks
are premium phone oh my god the one I
tell us that was so freemium but I've
seen them use Instagram like a million
times yeah well we need to be churning
out content if he's gonna become a
social media star that hey he needs to
leave his house he's gonna because it
does but it's so hard to get a picture
of him outside but then the leashes and
it's so ugly
New York is dusting it's not easy work
premium content no one ever said it was
easy
nobody said it was easy okay do you
think it's time I believe I have
shamelessly promoted myself enough and I
have I think I think I think so
I don't want to all so let's talk about
chance are the stars at the end Margo
yeah yeah look forward to hearing your
guys's update well that's Kardashians no
because we were had a show on Sunday I'm
so and also be awesome Atlanta premiered
yesterday and I think we should be
recapping it on the show so I'm going I
recorded it and I have to watch that and
Kardashians okay cool well without
further ado it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast and it's time for sure but
I have to share another interesting
story from Milwaukee at the Mean Green I
gave this girl a hug she was so cute I'm
like oh my [ __ ] you smell so good
she said simpered she signed on and she
smelled amazing right but then even
better is that Myanmar girl in the hotel
we're going to sleep and I was freezing
so I put on the sweater that I wore
during the mean Greek cause there's only
sweatshirt I had and oh my god poof I
smelled like Prada it was amazing like
what a wonderful way to sleep so if
anyone thinks that the small tempered
bottles aren't potent this is scientific
proof that it is small yet powerful just
like s Sanford is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes they have more than 600
designer brands for you to choose from
each month
choose the perfume you want to try and
they'll send you a 30-day supply if
you're not sure what type of scent
you're looking for you can sort and find
your new fragrance by brand style
occasion season and more plus they have
products from other categories like
skincare wellness and makeup they carry
brands like Coke re glam glow glow
recipe tart and so many others and with
an exclusive offer just for our
listeners you can get 30% off your first
month today that's only ten dollars for
your first fragrance go to scent bird
dot-com slash toast or use our code
toast for 30% off your first month again
that's
see ENT BIR g.com slash toast for you to
try your first perfume or cologne for
just $10 sign-on smell amazing there's
really no excuse to not smell amazing
also I know we're been co-hosted the
toast yesterday and we were in bed last
90 SEC are using a natural deodorant I'm
like why he's like I don't know your
glands it's really bad you should be
using a natural deodorant I'm like how
do you know that he said cope re
I'm like Ben Ben doesn't realize he's
been using Michael part for like three
weeks he was really you know he was
really concerned about you know putting
aluminum near your breasts when he said
that's what he said
yeah and I'm like I have been on the
natural it's quite the educational
program true let me say we're sponsored
by any be education connection it's
education connection get connected so
free I was just singing that song with
one my friends that I wondered is that a
regional commercial or electives
everyone know that I think everyone
knows it and then like Lindsay Lohan
like oh no she was doing commercials for
lawyer.com
I was working for an hourly wage I went
into high school didn't you greet still
I gotta make more just more education is
what I'm looking at if I get a degree I
will make a bigger salary so now I've
got to see which colleges are right for
me I went on the internet and fast
education connection I took something to
find out my direction I'm taking my
education connection Becky with the
right colleagues Buffy get connected
honest Oh what I'm [ __ ] Bangor that is
like ad agency like whoever came up but
that like deserves a Nobel Peace Prize
Grammy yes literally not even grab me
because musically but because it's like
it's hooked it's Liberty forever I'm
seeking that song about ladies we could
get kind of different free education
things we're good education connection
calm is this silhouette site I think
it's like and they want to sponsor the
toast like we will sing that song every
day play that song my dream it's so who
play instead of chose at the beginning
of every up yeah
education connection if you're watching
yeah free college money I would say you
have such a good commercial yeah like I
feel like 10 years ago like when you're
growing up was the Golden Age of
commercials like you didn't even mind
watching commercials because now like
people skip through them so much I feel
like companies are putting less creative
effort and to him like back in the day I
remember that Kodak commercial where the
girl's sister no the girls brothers
friends came over and they like store
history when they're in boxers they take
a picture to go that I mean I guess like
these days that we considered like
assault yet it was super cute commercial
back then very huge Wow
okay are you ready because these five
stories are each one stranger than the
next are they fast okay not the fastest
we've ever had but definitely we're
gonna talk about some people that we've
not talked about before and we're gonna
start with Jana Kramer who's opening up
about finding a woman's topless photo on
her husband's phone years after in
fidelities okay so a little backstory
Jana Kramer One Tree Hill I've got the
boy you've got the man country singer
she's a podcast and she fights with her
husband on it yeah like that's their
thing it's like they don't hide from
their audience ages they're the opposite
of Cassie and Colton in like the other
extreme way yeah like they are all their
dirty laundry and I think to them it's
like considered authentic and I think to
other people it's considered incredibly
strange yes so a while back like he had
cheated on her they separated for a
while they're working through it just a
lot of people will listen to her podcast
but for those of you who don't that's
the back story they're working through
it on the potty they're working through
it on the podcast but they are back
together now and Jana Kramer and husband
Mike house in are candidly discussing a
recent fight that triggered trusted
issues in their marriage on the latest
episode of their podcast wind down with
Jana Kramer and my cowson the pair
opened up about a recent incident
involving the singer going through her
husband's Apple watch and finding a
topless woman's photo that he had
deleted from his phone without informing
his wife quote I see it and I know the
right thing to do is go get Jana pull
her aside and say hey I just received
this I don't know what the hell it is
but I just need you to know I was
terrified to do so the former NFL player
recalled why would you be terrified if
you didn't do anything he's just
claiming some woman red and phone number
texted him a tittie pic yeah that's what
he's claiming quote Jenna and I have had
a
Gudrun recently like not a lot of past
stuff coming up we've been handling
situations pretty well handling triggers
pretty well talking things out it feels
like we were really building a lot of
foment emmm the father of 2 added
referring to the progress they had made
after his infidelities in 2016 it just
sucks as soon as we feel like we're
hitting a good patch my past behaviors
and my past actions come back to haunt
me
because I know I didn't handle it in the
way I had to it made it even worse
so he's claiming that someone sent him a
photo that he had no idea who it was and
he didn't like - he saved it like oh he
deleted it from his iPhone but she went
through his Apple watch oh she's a
psycho he deleted the text yeah like I
think he was just like oh and then it
doesn't delete from your Apple watch I
guess I'm just so not an Apple watch
special reason why you don't need an
Apple I'm 1,000% and you know what like
to me this feels so weird and invasive
like critiquing this argument like
asking for more details but like this is
what they're wanting of us like I
wouldn't it's someone if I've been out
like anyone in the celebrity realm like
gotta titty like I wouldn't care a man
whose tits were they how do you find it
on the Apple watch check like us being
so invested is so incredibly strange and
I think this is so weird and I have
literally no faith in their marriage I
know I think this is so weird I
understand if you got a random DM with
the teeny pic like these things happen
I've never known people I was reading
the toasters comments and like the
speculation is that it was some sort of
spam bot that like - seen before but if
that were true he would just tell her
right like this is so weird just you've
seen before yeah like in TIAA there's
like this one picture of a girl in a bra
that it's got around of like really yeah
and it's the same picture every time and
it could be that but I really don't
think it's a curse if it was that he
would've just been like you know what
where the [ __ ] is this but I don't think
he's either he's cheating either because
then this would have been a much like
bigger conversation but I'm just I've
never like how do you find yourself in a
position where you're getting spambot
titty pics not only that I'm not I'm not
getting I've never and how do you find I
sell fam calls a lot McCallum this
morning the IRS is always after me but
how do you find this IRS how do you find
yourself in a position to be going
through your husband's Apple watch like
she kinda she had it like a feeling that
she needed to look so I just have a
feeling that at that point in the
marriage egg maybe
time to let it go you know like give up
because if you're like so concerned with
your husband's [ __ ] Apple watch like
I just don't really feel like there's
longevity here yeah and I mean the whole
situation is weird but like it's not the
worst thing ever it's not like confirmed
infidelity say it was a spambot let's
play benefit of the doubt here like I
just can't believe they're talking about
this on their podcast right that is so
for a point of the podcast but I don't
know what anyone gets out of it like and
they should be having conversations like
this but when it's public you're not
gonna say everything that you're
thinking also they didn't speak for 24
hours after it happened until the
podcast yeah
my favorite didn't speak and then
they're like let's hash this out okay
devil's advocate here because sometimes
are you ever like having a fight and
you're like I wish people could hear
this to hear how right I am yes but like
I don't go and record it no and not when
it's still like deeply personal okay if
you and I were having an argument about
like something in the business like fine
like but like to have something about
like your marriage like it's so personal
this is so weird and like I can't
understand what the motives are for this
being the subject of your podcast like
are you that thirsty like is this a
thirst move because I didn't think in
their soul should they believe like
talking about on the podcast is gonna be
best for their relationship because
that's impossible
yeah also interesting factoid that I
that um I didn't read it
she then called the number and texted it
and it was like the bot was like sorry
hun can't talk on the phone do you want
me to come over oh that's no BOTS that's
so bad and I was and Janna was like you
texted my husband I would love to know
your correspondence please from one
woman to another as I was typing this
this is literate I was literally like
how is this happening again like I mean
these bats aren't getting like more and
more person that's true but I'm sorry in
the words of Rachel Green once a cheater
always a cheater yeah this is also like
claims like he like came out when he had
a sex addiction and has a sponsor so
shoot and he was like I was gonna call
my sponsor and Jenn was like why didn't
you tell messy and I don't want to know
that he's a second but I don't want to
know any of this information this is
disgusting like I want no part of this
and why are they shoving their problems
like people in the world anyway anyone
who listens to a podcast has enough [ __ ]
going on in their own world they don't
need to meet it I'm dumped taking on
them on this [ __ ] okay yeah yeah
I like it's just so crazy I mean awesome
but I feel like it speaks to the world
that we live in now where people really
feel like they need to air like their
dirtiest laundry in order to for people
like to listen and why is it so extreme
like you have to be Jana Kramer and
Michael where you're literally like
taking a dump on your podcast and
showing them the inside of your butt
hole or you're so fake you're like
Colton and Cassie like where everything
is fake and everything is but like it's
a facade like why can't anyone just be
in the middle like I feel like I'm in
the middle like me and then with that
all the time I still love him but we
fight all the time yeah and you talk
about the fact that you fight you're not
going to tell us your specific fights
like you follow us and you're not gonna
see your until say you follow say but
you're not gonna tell us why because
like nobody's [ __ ] business know
because it's nobody's [ __ ] business
and like what people fight about it's
like so it's such like a window into
their relationship which none of us need
a green of us need very maybe like off
the podcast we need because we're
sisters but aside from that if I was
just your co-host like I do not need no
no I don't need anything like I have and
I feel like this goes forever I'm like
we all have enough going on in our like
lives relationships career it's like
there is no space for us to be taking on
other people's problems
yeah and I feel as though when people do
stuff like this they they say so that
other people out there going through
something similar you know we're good
but one we're good - what's the moral of
the story here like are you gonna do
something about this you don't trust
your husband you walk on eggshells like
girl why are good thank you names like
the American camper and peace out peace
I don't know I know the story but I also
don't know their relationship like well
enough I don't listen to their podcast
so maybe there's some love there that's
that's pounding them together their love
their if they're really every time I
hear about them it's a terrible fight
it's cheating it's something that's
leaving like they have to have at least
like each other in order to put up with
each other
perhaps but also in this day and age if
you're doing a podcast like about the
inner workings of your relationship like
maybe you need that relationship in
order to be doing a podcast right that's
true like it's chicken in - yeah Shannon
I don't know I just think it's it's
really crazy yes and she seems like a
sweet girl
and then
her music I am was watching entourage
and she had a very small cameo in
Entourage where turtle was going back to
school and he was dating um Jamie uh
what's-her-name from The Sopranos Jamie
and Lannister no legal in Ziggler
yeah jamie-lynn Sigler yeah and he's
like so happy with her he can't believe
that he's dating like a celebrity and
then he goes to college and one of the
girls in his classes Jana Kramer and she
was like super young and she's so
beautiful and he like it's taunting
turtle and it's like a whole thing it's
like a love triangle and they do end up
sleeping together spoiler alert um and
then I was like whatever happened to her
acting career yeah I actually caught her
in a Hallmark like no country crush is
greater than Netflix one yes that's a
musical - yeah and on Hallmark starring
her and it was very bad and I had to
turn it off but she was fine but he just
wasn't going anywhere you having to turn
off the hallmark movie it must have been
awful it really was and like I left I
liked her and it was like a country vibe
but it was just not happening yeah it
was not happening anyways I hope these
two can work it out runs me a little bit
of Jesse James Decker yeah like in terms
of their career like had a moment as a
as an artist and now it's like a swirl
Decker isn't an actress no but I just
meant like singer why are they were like
a bonafide singer yeah yeah any singing
career now an influencer yeah yeah
sounds great it sounds like the dream
yeah remember when Jesse James Decker
was commenting all this on the CMA or
like a cm picture said like all the
country artists being like I can't
believe I wasn't invited what does like
Carrie Underwood and Miranda Lambert
like ya know Jen and Kramer commenting
yeah the same thing honestly believe me
commenting that I released a song like
it was so important yeah that was crazy
crazy I think she learned glass in them
okay are you ready for the next Tori
this one's for the snatchler this one
goes out to the snatchler is it because
he sent it to me Nick Jonas said to you
and the voice as a coach for season 18
Blake I'm gonna kick your ass okay when
I saw this I'm like this is not shocking
at all because if he washes Jonas
Brothers episode of song land he was
literally auditioning for the voice like
he was like oh could I get that F and
there go bum bum bum and then like float
out and it's like oh he's a voice coach
yeah I mean I think it's great Joe is it
voice Australia that's why he lived
there during that during the documentary
yet Spencer was the interesting actually
it's in their blood I guess and I feel
like Nick Jonas like he was like this is
his dream come true like yeah he's like
it's a little scary
because it's just like one step of Nick
like outside the joint it's like that's
what started to break up at first as I
know he kind of thought he was more
musically inclined to more musically
talented or vocally talented or
songwriting and he he wanted to take a
step out and now maybe he's feeling that
way again and needs like an outlet for
his expression and like the voice is
gonna be that and that it's gonna get
that big head again thinking that he
could do it how do we think so I think
that he's gonna bring the Joe Broz at a
time major mentor a preventive measure
it's like he got so stifled just being
one of the three last time that now
they're a threesome but they can each do
their own thing making this so that when
they come back to the group they're
happier and better did you watch the
attorney desk concert no so they have
like a small band for them and the guy
on the drums was the guy from dnce
yeah does he play on tour with them and
the drummer yeah he does this is nice of
Joe yeah he might have started with
Jonas Brothers when to dancing with Joe
and coming back me I don't know he's
like part of the yeah I love like seeing
I'm over time when people keep their
band members around cuz it really just
like I don't know it makes me think
they're like a good person I can't
explain it like they don't treat people
like they're disposable like Taylor
Swift when you watch positive editors
speak now or her red tour she's the same
guitar and bass and drummer like that's
cool like I like seeing keep people that
keep people around it feels like I don't
know makes me think they're grounded I
don't know why I think yeah it makes you
think that they're a pleasure to work
for yeah yeah I'm like no one wants
leave right and now I'm firing people
every day Yeah right look that up sort
of had him on town when she falls in
love with the guy who insert guitarist
yes he's hot and he was better than me
bad to the bone and but he wrote that
song she wrote the song he could be the
one about him and that is baby the best
song for Hannah Montana I don't know
about that but he's totally hatching so
rocking he's got everything that girls
wantin guitar cutie he plays it grew
that's the best song see you hear what
I'm saying it's pretty good it's pretty
good
speaking of Hannah Montana I fell down
in Georgia see what we're a bit homeless
that you actually fell because you have
to watch the restorations and I was
looking at Jojo see us Instagram and and
her tour and like I really am so I don't
understand what she does like she's on
tour she said she performs 19 songs I'm
assuming original songs so she has music
I know one DRM for 80 minutes and she
dances by the way she's a really good
dancer issues she's a Hannah Montana of
the younger generation she really is
like a singer dancer with her wigs and
and she sponsored by Nickelodeon I know
that's all I know about her that she
sponsored by Nikki located she's so and
dance crazy no it's not crazy but weird
it's like why doesn't she have a show
but she's a singer then I was just
watching one of her videos and she was
like laughing her way through the song
maybe was just like a funny song I'm so
confused as to like what this woman
Johnny
she got a Nickelodeon special like they
filmed her concert great like Netflix I
want to watch it me too because I am the
Hannah Montana of this younger
generation no wonder North West is
obsessed with you know I have more faith
in Jesse of his abilities just because
North West I feel like it's like
ruthless when it comes to talent and she
really sees something in Jojo see what I
know and you have to watch the episode
of Keeping Up because it's okay I'm
gonna tell Jesse well see what no just
you have it all yeah it's more
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa than we ever thought
all just Jojo see we'll look next to
North six-foot that's one of the most
shining six-foot-five next to Kim I've
ever give kids in adults from this show
is that JoJo's he was like 511 yeah and
she's 35 years old she's a chain-smoker
allegedly but she deaf I don't know
she's a chain smoker but she definitely
rips a jewel like well that's what Angie
wrote a blog saying that she is a chain
smoker
I didn't reveal it to be her once I
heard it I was like this might be true
this tracks
yeah yeah she definitely what did you
all every now and then um Nick Jonas is
I'm the voice that means our judges now
he's replacing Adam Levine no one
Stefani Gwen Stefani this is every six
no this is people hey chicks wrote an
article saying oh he's replacing animal
no sorry listen once vomit Adam Levine
has been he hasn't been on interesante
right and you know I was thinking when
Nick Jonas wasn't answer Mike who's he
gonna replace like honestly Gwen Stefani
like love her appreciate her but she is
not mr. Kyle I know I know but she this
like Gwen Stefani is like not the icon
that people make her out to be I'm sorry
I said it look at what Tonya rad went to
her concert in Vegas and was like her
and Brad Gretzky were like freaking out
like the way they you and I would forget
out to see Celine Dion like icon status
and they were like filming her concert
I'm like well I don't get it it was very
silly and childish like with the bananas
like I don't get it so that's how I know
how to spell bananas so I'm happy that
she met Blake Shelton on the show and I
feel like we can you know send her off
like a dove yeah we can move on yeah so
it's Nick Blake Kelly and John logic
obviously that sounds like a great okay
and mega mentor well that's just for
maybe this season I'm not sure if all
four judges turned around for you who
would you go with Kelly Clarkson she
would go with Blake Shelton and then try
and marry him yeah can I say something
about Blake Shelton like he's been on
the show since beginning now he's the
only one him in the Adam Adam Levine
were the only two left now he's the only
one left um what do you think is so
special about him then he's like stood
the test of time like do you think
they're gonna bring him a new country
person soon no I think that a he really
is like a country music icon like yes
you could bring it like a Thomas rapidly
so he's like someone has me I think he's
so hot
three he's so funny like he's just like
pure personality which i think is what
they need like Kelly Clarkson that's why
she's been sticking around cuz she has
personality I also think it has to be
mutual and the network has to want them
and they want to they still have to want
to be there right I can imagine that
like Adam Levine was over it I think you
know get over it but I think this is
like the perfect thing for Blake Shelton
to be doing because he has this high
country career now he gets to be
mainstream yeah he's also like for Emily
May brought him his wife yeah like I
think he gets a lot out of it
you know they're married they're not
like I promised I think I would have no
Lake Shelby well they're definitely
engaged no snacks Larry you're lying
they'll ever just think they are but
like they're not because they're older
like you think it just hmm
also he still on because he wins usually
like every season yeah I feel like it
makes a lot of sense because he's
really like a family guy like at the end
of the day Adam Levine wants like rock
out with his [ __ ] out you know he's not
looking for like an NBC like he made his
money and he laughs but you know what's
so interesting is that he left the boy
switches on NBC and he is an executive
producer on sunland so which is on NBC
so I don't know I just think he's weird
he's like over the whole TV thing and
then like he needs more Sun yes he has
like in a me see contracts and Mike's
mother right uh yeah I guess they're
dating which is so weird right I think
they were engaged because they've been
together for a long time when you're of
a certain age like you just assume that
they're married no but I remember I
think they started dating around the
same time in attack and I started dating
and then I heard they got engaged like
so soon everyone thought they were
engaged and they were like nah didn't
happen the disillusion of Blake Shelton
and Roberts marriage is one of the I'm
so happy for him it's one of the
craziest things like I wouldn't think of
a time where Blake Shelton amirite
Miranda Lambert we're married like I
don't even remember that time in my life
you know like when they used to show up
at a war chest together we weren't
really people Yeah right yeah Young was
crazy times crazy times
speaking of super coach Taylor Swift
Taylor Swift on SNL oh one to get your
guys's thoughts um I wasn't crazy about
the choice of fall Scott it's not my
favorite song of course she's saying it
well and I enjoyed the saxophone but
it's like this is your moment girlfriend
like people are always like doubting you
like to show them your best like very
summer the man like anything else like I
don't I just thought it was like a huge
stage where like I was just like it
wasn't bad it just wasn't like her
performance of leather like I'll listen
to on repeat I thought it was so good
that was good like I enjoy it she says
like I just needed to hear her sing
cruel summer and scream he looks up
grinning like a demo like then wait I
heard a few theories and one of them is
that remember how she was singing for
Scott you are a huge oversized blazer
yeah and actually if you look at like
her last five or six cross outfits
they've all been Blazers in somewhere
yeah like laser dress blazer shorts like
blaze are the man like God you know but
she didn't sing it no but for a single
oh I don't want the man to be single I
like the mass number to be a single me
too it's just about her singles like she
is weird about her singles um but if
you're gonna wear a blazer that's like
so apples and oranges and
she should have performed the man she
wouldn't have performed cruel summer
because it's just like too good of a
song and I guess she doesn't like to
like showcase her obviously good some
write me because the other ones need
help maybe maybe she doesn't do that
both of us not even close to like it is
much hot hot it's about I'm half of the
album's yeah like maybe she's just
trying to like race all ships here or
maybe she don't like the sax club
saxophone vibe would be like perfect for
SNL I don't know you see like if you
close your eyes and you listen to her
performance like it sounds like any
other artist who's like coming up now
with their like breathy tones and it
doesn't set her apart at all agreed
agreed nor did that outfit like it just
it looks like she was trying to be
someone that she's not we talked about
love her because I was so great perfect
oh my god one of these earrings and by
the way the more that I listened to the
song lover I like it's going up the
scale yeah I think one of her best songs
ever it is so good so these earrings
that I am wearing are ones we wear all
the time like I have a million pairs
they would lose sight by Alison Lou and
I actually know that Taylor stripped
where's Allison Lou jewelry a lot but
she wears like the custom expensive
stuff and it couldn't believe that she
wore earrings that I have green lucite
hoops I have them I know we all loved
the monochromatic aesthetic I like the
green piano of course I loves that that
was a beautiful classic Taylor
perfection and so it was like just a
strange dichotomy we were going back
into like reputation knives and it's
like bring us out I remember us deliver
us from reputation into cruel summer
like you know I'm starting to feel like
reputation is so underrated yeah by the
way that's always what happens when 1989
came out I was like honestly this pop
electric [ __ ] is like not my dad and no
a 1989 come out came out it was
everything it was mainstream it was
because I didn't like that the entire
kit I wanted a country red
mission it took over the world but
reputation was just like a little too
heavy-handed at the time and in
hindsight it's like it's fun to listen
to but everyone was looking for so many
undertones and she was just like giving
them out yeah you know no totally like I
had this realization maybe a month ago I
could not stop us into reputation I was
like this is just art yeah it that's I
feel like that's what makes her music so
special it's almost like timeless yeah
cuz honestly like I'll go back and
listen to [ __ ] timber girl and I'm
like wow this shit's lab to make you
invisible a lot because the of the
Cornelia Fox swaps yeah
like she's like a fine wine there's just
music gets better with age yeah or like
a cheese an aged cheddar smells okay you
ready for our next story I am but not
before I let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by hellofresh
America's number one meal kit get easy
seasonal recipes and pre measured
ingredients delivered right to your door
all you have to do is cook and enjoy how
a fresh makes cooking delicious meals at
home a reality regardless of your
comfort in the kitchen someone's calling
me I'm in the middle of something
from step-by-step recipes to pre
measured ingredients you'll have
everything you need to get a WoW worthy
dinner on the table in about 30 minutes
say goodbye to endless grocery store
trips and takeout food takeout food
hellofresh has you covered
you can break out of your dinner rut
with hello freshest 20 plus seasonal
chef Curie the recipes each week there's
something for everyone from family
recipes to calorie smart and vegetarian
which is I know what you ordered yes
some vegetarian and chihuahuas I just
got my hello fresh delivery I'd like
three little bags of food that's ready
today so compact when things come to our
house I take it everything's
pre-measured it makes it so easy for
like you know amateur chefs like me
hello fresh has more five-star recipes
than any other meal kids so you know
you'll get be getting something
delicious for 80 dollars off your first
month of hellofresh go to hellofresh
comm slash toast 280 and enter the code
toast 80 again for $80 off the first
month of hellofresh go to hello fresh
calm slush toast 80 and enter the code
toast 80 I'm you can easily change your
delivery days or food preferences or
skip a week whenever you need really
just for the modern woman like who you
know is busy get it or the modern man
like sign on eat well feel good sign on
get full yeah it's it's good stuff
anyway I read that we should be eating a
lot of fruit today I hate fruit just for
the past tomorrow it's something about
like I don't know just something about I
was actually thinking today about like
cuz we had this whole like pizza night
plan but I cousine see I was like I
really shouldn't eat that much because
whenever I eat so much I wake up
starving yes no but it was amazing
apples in the kitchen here I have the
best apple oh man oh really they are we
failed I'm not going to eat so much
pizza but I just want like a slice of
pizza and some pasta and then I'll feel
good okay you know I'm just worried
about accessing it's like I want to be
smart like with like my nutrition Oh
value of like what will keep me like the
least hungry tomorrow yeah
while you struggle regardless drink a
lot of water today yeah but like what
that dehydrate whatever I don't know
yeah you gotta took a ton of water and
fruit okay next up botched botched
botched Paul Nassif but dr. Paul Nassif
is married
doctors botched doctor for micro and
acid is married you guys this is so
exciting he's a precious gem of man and
he sound love Paul Nassif looks so
different now than when we first saw him
on TV being miserably married to
Adrienne Maloof mm-hmm like that was
such a miserable marriage like for so
long people just like thought it was a
good marriage
they just chalked it up to them
bickering like marriage is supposed to
be mr. right but now we've learned
that's not the case I'm really so happy
for him because he seems really happy
like and he really bounce back yeah him
a Terry Dubrow just like took the e
network by storm and never looked back
no never looked back like he didn't look
Paul Nassif didn't has not looked back
once do you remember when him and
Adrienne got divorced and then she
didn't show up to the reunion that was
like so crazy and it's like people now
show up to the reunion having done like
so much worse and they generally
couldn't Maloof couldn't face the ladies
just like having gotten divorced no it
wasn't the divorce it was this Larry oh
he's the surrogate um someone like
Adrienne's chef talking about Lisa
usually petty [ __ ] yeah she should have
gone of course and I can't believe they
still let her film from time to time
when she was in breach of contract like
that's a big no-no yeah but I'm laying
her like throwing her a bone here and
there it's actually worse but it just
reminds her what she lost um also did
you know that in the very first episode
of shits Creek when the rose family is
still rich and they show their mansion
the mansion that they use is Lisa
Vanderpump's old house when she used to
live near Adrienne Maloof like and they
use it they lived in the same gated
community is it yeah what was that house
called I always try and remember
Villa Villarosa is now was a Villa
Blanca
nope that's the restaurant there the
house had a name I'd have to watch it
was one no I'll just google it I tried
googling it before what yeah it like
invades me
it's Villa something I don't know but
the house has a name you assume it's a
Ellis I'm
but I don't know if it was a villa if
anyone can remember it I mean no you
wouldn't know that original house was so
crazy mm-hmm oh I want to know what it
was called
if anyone can remember I will be forever
grateful I sure wasn't just Villa Blanca
positive positive or in the comments if
you can let us know uh anyway he's just
wanted to give a big congrats to upon us
if his wife looks like so beautiful they
got married in Santorini she's Greek is
he Greek um he is now
okay no he's definitely not actually you
might be nassif nassif um Nassif Adam
anyways lovey like it's so happy I
wonder if she'll make an appearance
ooh oh my god I felt so weird maybe it's
just whistled like I would have she'll
make an appearance on the channel Villa
Casa Bella Rosa no no it was Villa
something whatever okay I just like the
days of Adrienne Maloof mum where she
had that um vodka line and she did the
fashion show it was like the worst party
ever
no I should go yes Maloof hoof I forgot
about that that was the golden age of
television yeah it really was
okay next story is really funny Alec
Baldwin's family hustled by fake Statue
of Liberty tour operator what 30 rock
star Alec Baldwin was hustled by a fake
Statue of Liberty tour operator while
out sightseeing with his wife hilarya
and their kids
Baldwin sent an Instagram post that the
family shelled out more than $40 per
ticket for a tour of Liberty Island but
instead found themselves being escorted
toward a bus oh I kid you not we paid
then we read the tickets he raised in
the post no one ever mentioned new
[ __ ] get on the bus Baldwin upset
over being bamboozled went on to explain
at the family instead opted for the
Staten Island Ferry which offers a view
of lady liberally Lady Liberty for free
this is a scam Baldwin wrote take the
scat
in ferry it's the best ride in New York
he posted it he's not wrong about that
he's not worrying about that he posted
an image of his ticket which reads tours
are us see New York from the water the
destination on the ticket was Liberty
New Jersey but by the way you can see
the Statue of Liberty from Liberty New
Jersey for sure but you could also see
it like from the Statue of Liberty or
from anywhere else honestly it doesn't
sound like these people like hoodwink
Tim it just sounds like he wasn't paying
attention
no it's definitely false Haverty I have
been to Liberty New Jersey to the Statue
of Liberty and said you're going to
Liberty New Jersey it is very misleading
okay but Liberty New Jersey they have
this outdoor I've been there they have
this outdoor like it looks like the
Seaport almost and you could see the
Statue of Liberty like I'm saying like
no I'm sure that and that's what like
these are get beautiful these people are
selling something but like if I'm going
to see the Statue of Liberty I don't
want to go to Liberty New Jersey but I'm
saying this is a beautiful place to
snoop but if I'm going I'm buying if you
get to go to the Statue of Liberty like
I want to be in the Liberty's belly it
seems like Alec Baldwin could have paid
like a little bit more attention that's
all I'm saying probably be like it 40
hours you take it like you think you're
going to Statue of Liberty that's true
but also like alec baldwin just a type
of guy who like peruses the streets and
buys tickets from scalpers so it doesn't
have like an assistant to like I don't
think is help our thing is the company
yet twinners plush tours are s it's so
crazy like celebrities like do that like
I've lived in New York my whole life
I've never seen the Statue I've never
seen a moral of the story is don't go to
the statute list yeah I don't even try
I've been to the Empire State Building
yes I went to the observatory I've never
been it was so windy I was actually
scared I was gonna like fly away I went
to Governors Island yeah I've been to
Governors Island not Ellis not Ellis not
Ellis have not been I've been literally
not what's governor's eyelid why have
you been here we went on a field trip
there seemed we did like senior so yeah
I've been there maybe no I didn't go so
I never paid attention to where they
took us so many islands around the city
and Randall Randall's I've been yep
have you been to Rikers Island oh yeah
that's where the prison is yes yeah you
can actually see you're in there right
when we used to watch Law & Order and
they would go to Rikers Island
tell Marty who she was born we did yeah
yeah I don't remember that oh yeah you
were born in Rikers Island so you have a
bad streak you're badass oh man that is
such a funny like losery thing for kids
to say obviously we're very creative
we're so creative yeah creative I think
a lot of my creativity came from
watching Degrassi like it was a whole
other world for me you know yeah
not from I mean that's not where my
creativity came that's how I learned
what rape was where Degrassi oh yeah
they were it was teaching us new things
that's true yeah the grass he was like a
crazy job yeah the kids we're [ __ ]
nuts you know yeah but doing crack you
got a little too unrealistic idea
actually look we're his parents
you know like an everyday something this
crazy right right all right okay I'm
like Drake they drink it don't drink it
well machine grinds after I know - I
know we couldn't go back totally you
can't go from the Beverly Hills back to
Canada okay bit story a little tech news
because Instagram dark mode is here I
saw Instagram is rolling out a dark mode
option the ladies the latest major app
to latch on to the eye strain reducing
battery saving chic looking trend that's
sweeping the globe oh I had no idea it
was ice like that's why hmm
the photo-sharing zap new appearance is
similar to its rivals it's embracing the
darkness by flipping the default white
background to black and gray Instagram
made the theme available to iOS and
Android users in an update release
Monday according to instagrams chief
Adam oh sorry
- activate dark you're always talking
about autumn oh sorry yeah and you know
what I watched this and um there's a
docu-series on Netflix called I don't
know but it's about it features
different designers like aesthetic
abstract designers they did one on the
Instagram the guy who did does
instagrams design he did redesign their
logo there when that happened and it was
looking like a camera was in like an
old-school camera
they showed how they got to this logo
and like the loop new logo makes so much
sense when you watch how they got there
but like when it debuted like it was a
huge failure it was crazy everybody
hated it but always whenever any tech
company like makes a big change
everyone's like this SADS my more than
Facebook we configure their entire
homepage and there was like little you
could like be joined Facebook groups
like get your Facebook back to the old
way and there was like hacks yeah we're
all fine it's always like this SAG's and
then everyone moves on with wait my
phone updated last night while I was
asleep which is like just rude like I
want I want to give you some rich in you
probably didn't get permission no it's
just like right it's like when your
phone's plugged in the tomatoes like
whatever I'm not thinking about it
whatever until I woke up and I had all
these decisions to make oh my god 8:45
in the morning would you decide and I
decided to keep my phone with the white
background just because I don't like the
black but now that I know that it saves
battery yeah I might have made a
decision permanently I don't to go back
and change it but I'd like I like the
way that old sound every every app is
different like I have to give all these
permissions now for all these different
things you could have like you give a
photo for all of your give all of your
contacts did you guys see that at the
photo when I was texting in the chat
today no with the purple background and
my emoji let me see yeah yeah so the new
the new update is great but I also see
here for me I feel like the software
it's just gonna [ __ ] up my phone so that
I get anyone know it's like whenever any
tech company of Oz it's like met with
such angst and rage because it's
annoying like you're disturbing our
activity I know and sometimes it lands
but then sometimes it doesn't like
remember this snapchat update they never
bounced back
never wow that's so true you know so I
don't know maybe it really like has to
do with these people who make these
decisions like making the decisions for
the right reasons right that's a great
point mm-hmm well I'm looking forward to
trying out Instagram talk mode I go on
Twitter talk about sometimes and also
apparently you can go on text dark mode
did you know that Olivia tolling no yes
isn't that what I'm talking about
thank you no all the texts it's like
it's dark yeah like it's black memory
yeah that was what I'm talking about
that I had a choice yeah I don't think
that's for me right but and everyone
saying that ice easier on your eyes
yeah but for the blue light whatever
yeah um let's talk about tensing with
the Stars okay because very sadly the
love of my life had to go home it was
his time
it was time he made it further than I
ever thought he was going to and while I
was sad I'm glad
Malena still around so let me go to LA
next week we can go see her dance all I
wanted um everyone is like talking about
Hannah Browns performance I thought you
really thought to use what did she do
she shaded her exes no magazine yeah bug
like she said they went to one of those
rage rooms you know where you're like
and she said for one second she was like
these are my ex-boyfriends and that was
the story she ate like that it wasn't
that wasn't like really what it was
about I said what she danced she danced
to I don't care I love it and she did
the don't care yeah she did like some
like I mean I'm not beautiful as she was
amazing and she has gotten like so home
yeah it's the craziest thing but she
looked amazing and it was the dance and
I'm obviously not gonna remember but
it's like a very like structure
structured and like she couldn't smile
that was the whole thing and all she
does the smile she hides behind her fake
smile that's what she said so the
hardest part was to not be able to smile
cuz that's just like her go-to and she's
like uncomfortable or whatever but she
really she honestly did amazing she's
really good she is really good like she
probably will win based on merit but I
think it's also like a lot of the
network really pushing for her because
she's an ABC star like it would be a
great moment for ABC you know but not
not to take away from the fact that she
is very talented and like is one of the
better dancers second I would say my top
three would be like her james Van Der
Beek and Lauren and Allie Brooks thank
you and even though I don't like Allie
Brooke I want to like her so much do you
know what it is like I feel like to me
what borns doing is so much more
impressive Lauren it's absolutely no Dan
yeah background where it's like Ali has
a dance background James has a dance
background and so does Hannah so like to
me I think of the actual task at hand
like which is learning to dance Lauren
is doing the best job right was the
sausage oh boy it's according to how to
lube lay it is the bullfighting dance oh
yeah yeah yeah
and I just want to say Shawn Spencer
dancers do bomb Bolle oh great great
song by the way did you see that video a
little clip of lamar odom scratching his
not that's so funny like he really
doesn't understand like even though he
filmed a reality show for like a couple
years he learned his own club but it
wasn't live this is live yeah I don't
think he understand
like how cameras work and like even
though he's not being spoken to like
he's still on camera yeah look he
definitely thought it was like totally
fine
oh for sure but now he's gone yeah very
sad but had to go and I feel like I was
shocked when I was in the bottom two
you know what krump can't catch a burger
he's so mean to him oh my god so good
and he's very coordinated and he might
not be like the most perfect answer but
he's not at the point yet where he
should be in the bottom two I feel like
three people need to go home and then
maybe he'll be it no no it means no
sense and ever like even last week when
he danced I was like loving watching his
dance and then the judges were like that
was terrible I was like it was
why does Len keep giving him fives I
said it's like it's borderline like
rigged no it's giving that lesson say it
but it's borderline like laces with Crum
oh he's a great smile he looks cute he's
open he's doing such a good job he
always gets better
no I know it makes me think I'm like
what don't they like my krama no I know
I thought that as like it's actually
really weird like they gave like I don't
know I don't know it makes no sense and
honestly I'm not loving for james van
der beek like I am I love him
except I have to say like the
contestants do a really good job of like
documenting their weeks on social media
like I find it so funny and entertaining
to watch them in studio that my practice
like that with their apartments I just
really enjoyed that also Leah Remini I
loved her last night what did she do she
was a guest judge oh yeah I know I
stayed for the judging oh no but using
estrogen she's just saying everything we
were saying like she forelimb was it
Lamar or was it I don't know she knew
that like the judges were once again
given give him a shitty score so he gave
she gave Lamar a 6 and to defeat that
Len and Bruno each gave before
Oh because like she wanted to ask his
score and they were like nah [ __ ] that I
have my lowest skip through the scoring
I find it to be so unimportant like like
first of all then the day all it really
matters is voting and second of all like
I don't agree with any of the judges
like when they give a forum I thought
that was a champ you know I know I don't
I don't agree with any of the judges and
I find them so I don't believe Lee
annoying you're just watching Jackie
she's going like this I find them to be
really annoying too and like not
relatable I'm like I just don't get them
at all you know I know and I find only
one who I kind of like is carry on oh my
god I can't stand this paper I know to
be like so extra and thirsted that heaps
you've got to like shut up yeah it's
like a dick
Liz for people to bail him like I think
he's like a villain I don't really like
him like he's like Simon Cowell karahan
like Gibbs critique and then also gets
compliments like you have to do both in
order to be a good judge of mine in my
opinion I understand I just find her so
annoying like once again it's like
sometimes she like wakes up and she's
like oh I'm in a good mood and so I'll
be nice it's like I'm gonna be evil text
sure the judging is so inter
unpredictable yeah um I what else was I
gonna say I can't remember I'm just
loving it no like it really is just so
enjoyable to watch you said there's so
many commercials like oh my god maybe
now what as it gets smaller it'll be
like each commercial break there's like
two dances not just one it's torture
actually that wouldn't make any sense it
it's so annoying
yeah but I'm just I'm loving it and you
know we'll see who wins okay I go like
I'm I'm Lloyd him I'm gonna catch up on
Real Housewives of Atlanta today and
keeping up with the kardashians recap
that any ROC is on tonight yes I made
some more strides in watching the hills
on the plane I didn't finish it but just
like once again loving Mischa Barton
really hating Justin Bobby and honestly
I want to talk to you about this I don't
know if you agree with me like I'm not
totally hating Stephanie Pratt hating
really hating I think the like what are
you up to
um Thanksgiving friendsgiving oh my god
she's she's unbearable she is blitz
arena okay well did they go to Vegas yet
and they couldn't end up coming yeah
yeah and like her talking about the
fires you know she's like she's like
nuts I don't like Audrey I don't dislike
Stephanie because I like Audrina like
right I don't feel any type of way about
Teresa's argument like so that he didn't
do anything no but like 70 is being not
a good friend she's being shady and like
that's pretty new to Audrina they're not
friends but they started as friends and
like she's like going and like meddling
between her and Justin Bobby and like
she's totally in love with Justin Bobby
1,000% I just don't like girls like that
I don't I don't like girls like that
either but like I also don't like girls
like Audrina who like she was like I
don't care if you guys heard me up
meanwhile it's all she's spoken about
for the last two weeks like I know yes
just right like well if you don't care
like why do you keep talking about it
like you don't care
yeah no I do you think you and Justin
Bobby were getting back together but
you're not yeah which would have been
like so
like ten years goes by and like change
tack same spot we ID like her but like
why is she on the show she's never there
I don't know and that's how it was ten
years ago too though that's true heidi
becoming a christian pop star is
everything everything when she was like
I'm gonna get back into music I like
rolled my eyes and then when she was
talking about how like she wants to do
faith-based music I was like wait that's
actually an amazing idea
yeah and that song the service right was
like kind of good no it's a great idea
yeah keep watchin yeah I'm really
enjoying it like I'm not running through
it because like it's just fun to watch
when I'm on the plane I like Brody and I
like Kaitlyn and I just find the family
dynamics to be so interesting like when
Brandon Thomas Lee went to the Jenners
for Thanksgiving cuz like he like
doesn't have like a family it was like
kind of sad mm-hmm and his dad is like
engaged to Brittany that was my start he
kept talking about a sad fiancee I'm
like she's an instagramer like I know
her yeah it was crazy yeah all good
stuff it's really the golden age of
television people like we're just living
in the time like the housewives are
coming back it's really exciting it's a
golden age of reality television
yeah actually if you watch the Emmys
they'll have you feel and such amazing
news that I just feel like not everybody
is aware of what Riverdale comes back
tomorrow and dynasty comes back on
Friday
dr. Steve and I spoke about Riverdale
coming back yeah okay but did you talk
about how dime see something back no
because I'm just so excited and Ben
doesn't watch dynasty right but it's
back on Friday is Liam alive I don't
know I think he is he better be out I'll
riot in the streets Wow Hugo if you're
not in the dynasty and Facebook group
you should have it up it's pretty late
um we love you guys thank you so much
for listening
wow that was only an hour but like feels
like we've been sitting here for six
hours because we covered so much ground
we really did you think we talked faster
than ever um tickets available to my
shows and hitting la San Diego San
Francisco all next week
West Coast week tickets available all
Carl no job calm thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching on
YouTube feel free to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up leave a comment you
know it's to what's available as a
podcast but you know if you're listening
Jess's podcast right now we're valve on
iTunes Spotify stitcher huh public radio
I already all the radios all the ways
cast lots so feel free to subscribe over
there leave a review over there leave
five stars about how beautiful smart
funny we are we love you guys so much we
hope you have an amazing day and we will
see you tomorrow make sure to subscribe
to our patreon Channel WWE not tomorrow
oh my god no tomorrow so yeah we'll see
on Thursday Thursday I hope everyone has
an easy and meaningful fast marketing
Matoba you know reflect on your sins if
you said something mean about maybe this
year apologize to God because I read it
and it hurt my feelings but I forgive
you but I do I forgive you if I did
anything to offend anyone this year it's
too [ __ ] bad love you guys marfa too
much of our happy you will not happy Yom
Kippur
I'll see you on the other side Thursday
where we'll all be looking much slimmer
know what we won't because doesn't even
work like that it's not even a diet aid
you